alors donc cette sitcom que vous
préparez on a vu comment s'appelle
making-of donc titre provisoire
voilà titre provisoire quatre faits le
rôle de l'acteur et vous olivier le rôle
du réalisateur sait quoi en gros c'est
c'est l'histoire d'un film à travers un
making-of c'est une comédie et donc on
le making of on voit beaucoup maintenant
sur les dvd dans les bonus chose qui
parle aux gens donc voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un film dont on ne saura
jamais l'histoire finalement il
reconnaîtra juste le titre du film et
c'est les aventures du comédien du
réacteur de la maquilleuse de des autres
partenaires de l'équipe pendant comme ça
six épisodes et c'est un gros gros gros
derrière qu'on entend de décrire et
qu'on va tourner en février qui sera à
son apn de canal en janvier tu le vends
bien voyons bien tu ses méthodes enfin
je parle pas comme ça avec moi alors et
puis lorsqu'il faut dire aussi à nos
amis téléspectateurs c'est que le 28
décembre sur comédie il ya une spéciale
kadéos et ça c'est très important aussi
pour tous vos fans voilà